I've been working on a song of ice and  fire since 1991 and I think fans will be  surprised as to what's coming up  Joffrey adopts an adorable lion cub and  learns the true meaning of Christmas  next season  the Dragons talk after season four we're  doing a complete reboot with Daenerys  Targaryen played by Zachary Quinto Arya  Stark discovers the ruins of the Statue  of Liberty on the beach and realizes she  was on earth the whole time Hodor Jaime  Lannister forms Kingslayer  the first heavy metal band in Westeros  the lords and ladies of Winterfell are  saved by their long-lost cousin the  creator of the Iron Throne Tony Stark  winter comes it's not so bad cozy Hodor  crap I I was supposed to write more  books  [Laughter]  [Music]